Great. You're listening to radio,
the podcast from w.
C. N. N. P. R. Hello everyone.
This is radio lab, the podcast.
I'm Jad Abumrad and I am Robert
Krulwich and Jed sick. Yes. Here,
but that doesn't mean that we shouldn't
explain to you the situation to you,
the podcast Listener,
r n there's been some confusion
here among our our podcasts,
which is exactly what's going
on in the last five podcasts.
You've listened to completely
produced hour long programs. Yes.
That's why we began radio lab as
a radio show, our long programs,
which we work very, very hard on. Yeah,
I mean I think of us as having two.
We have radio labs for the radio,
which are hour long programs and you've
just heard a bunch of those and then we
have radio labs just for you sign up.
Those are called the podcast and we
could do stuff on the podcasts that are a
little less formal and not that were,
there'll be formed on the radio,
but it's just a looser form so we can
come short length shorter or longer or
longer. Yeah, yeah, that's
true. That's true. We've ran,
we ran conversations between you and
various smarty pants that have run pretty,
really wrong and have been, have
been great or close to forever.
But the point is, this is now the
beginning of a podcast, so this is not,
and if you're wondering where
to find us on the radio,
the issue there is that we're on the
radio at different times all over America.
So you have to ask your local
station when they run radio labs,
sometimes in the morning,
sometimes in the evening,
but the podcast is anytime
you choose. That's right.
And starting with this podcast,
this post season five podcast, uh,
I want to read to you Mr Kroll,
uh, the second paragraph of a, uh,
uh, an article that was recently
in the New York Times. Okay.
Have you heard about this?
Uh, this fellow Brock,
I know about the New York Times. Oh
Bro, yes, I heard him too. Okay. Well,
new researchers have documented,
I'm quoting here what
they call an Obama effect,
showing that a performance gap between
African Americans and whites on a 20
question test administered
before Mr Obama's nomination,
all but disappeared when
the exam was administered,
after his acceptance speech and again
after the presidential election.
So to back up, that means it translated
into normal English. Yes. Go ahead.
That um,
some researchers decided to give a 20
question test to a bunch of people.
They were young people and
older people do just that.
You're going to take a
test. It's a GRE test.
It's a verbal test that you take to go
to graduate school before they take the
test, they have to list
their race. Yes, they do.
So you put down your race
and then you take the test.
Now the first time they administered
the test was sometime last year before
Barack Obama was a big deal.
Yes. And blacks performed poorly.
Poorer than whites. Yes. Eight poorly.
So whites on average at that point
answer 12 questions that have 20 correct.
And black subjects answered
only 8.5 on average out of 20.
So that's a significant difference.
Or that was a small sample.
Then they gave the exact same 20
question test [inaudible] gres again, the
verbal to a group of people after Barack
Obama had become the nominee of the
Democratic Party, had given an acceptance
speech in, in Denver, Colorado,
and was a pretty famous
and important guy. Yes.
And then they give it yet again after
Barack Obama had been elected president of
the United States. So there's, there's
these multiple of test takings.
And what they noticed was after Barack
Obama had become fabulous blacks taking
the test,
scored about the same as whites
before Barack Obama had been fabulous,
blacks performed more
poorly. And there's a,
there's a longstanding reason
for the previous performance,
but the new performance
that's very interesting. Pretty
stunning. But I mean we should say,
but as by way of caveat to that,
this isn't really preliminary study,
it's not been peer reviewed.
You guys haven't looked it over.
Not a huge number of
subjects in the study,
but there was a last very intriguing yes.
And there is actually precedent for
this, uh, for this, um, way of thinking.
The precedence goes back to a psychology
professor named Claude Steele.
I got a job offer.
This is in the 80s at the University of
Michigan and it was part psychology and
part to administer a minority
student program there. And um,
in the process I saw data that surprised
me when he saw was a troubling trend.
Two kids would enter Michigan,
one was black, one was white.
They come in at the exact same
level, same skills, same sat scores.
So theoretically they should do
the same when they get to Michigan.
But without fail or almost
without fail, after one semester,
the black kid was winding up with lower
grades. How much lower? Pretty, pretty,
um, pretty dramatic. At least
two thirds of a letter. Grades,
meaning if the white kid got an a,
the black kid who should be getting an a
too is instead getting a B or a B plus,
that's significant. That's significant.
That's significant. And he also,
by the way,
saw this performance gap between
women and men when it came to match.
At the same time,
same degree in advanced math
courses, it was comparable.
I learned this as a national phenomenon.
If I was to walk into almost any
college class in the United States,
I'd have a very high probability
of finding exactly that
[inaudible]
what could explain these differences.
There was something there that people
didn't understand and that we certainly
didn't understand till he figured he
would start with the woman in math issue.
He brought a bunch of women
in and a bunch of men,
what brought them into the
laboratory one at a time,
gave them a half an hour section of the
graduate record exam you take if you're
a math major, very, very
difficult math, and sure enough,
the woman who had all the same credentials
coming into that situation performed
dramatically worse than the men.
Worse as in it'd be a couple
hundred points on an sat testing.
It was a big effect.
So Claude Steele thought,
all right, step one complete.
I've got a lab situation that
resembles the real world. Good.
Now the next step is to
tweak things a little bit.
See if I can mess around with it.
Nope.
Normally in these situations,
the test giver has got a little white
lab coat on and he brings in a big stack
of cellophane wrapped tests.
He puts a clock on the table.
That's all. It's all you know.
It's like that's it's gonna
intimidate almost anybody.
Maybe that's what's happening. He
thought, what if I took away the clock,
took away the coat and most importantly
right before the test I had the test
giver. Instead of saying the normal,
I'm going to give you
a test pre test thing.
Maybe instead say something like this.
You may have heard that a women
don't do as well as men on difficult
standardized math test.
You may have heard that,
but that is not true for
this particular test.
This particular test does not show
gender differences. Never has never will.
He wondered if maybe saying that simple
sentence before giving the test would
have an effect
and sure enough,
I wouldn't be here if their performance
didn't go up and go up to match that of
the equally skilled men, that
performance gap totally vanished.
She look at this thing, so we
raced and did it very quickly.
The same kind of an experiment
with African Americans.
They're the pretest
disclaimer went like this
is an instrument that we use to study
problem solving and it is not diagnostic
of individuals intellectual ability.
In other words, this is not a test
of your intelligence. I repeat,
not an IQ test,
so just do the best you can with
that simple disclaimer at the start.
Same kind of an effect.
The black students and the
white students were now equal.
Just recently a Ryan Brown and
Eric Day did a clever treatment.
They,
there is an IQ test which is nonverbal
called the advanced progressive matrices
has figures, very abstract.
It got lines crossing that you
have to match and so on. X,
it's essentially pattern match diamonds
with dots and totally visual and so they
can represent that test
as as it is as an IQ test.
It's in fact seen as the gold standard
of IQ test because it's cool culture
free. There's no math, there's no reading
because it doesn't involve language.
Or You could represent the exact
same test as a puzzle puzzle. Puzzle.
Meaning you can give an IQ test to a
bunch of kids and the blacks will perform
worse. But if you give that same test,
lose the word test, lose the word IQ.
You just call it a puzzle.
The black participants suddenly jump
up in their performance. Basically,
we got a reversal. When you
represent represented as a puzzle,
blacks perform as well as white.
They did. Yeah. That's all it takes.
Just change a few words.
[inaudible].
In fact, there's even
better research on this, uh,
by a guy named Jeff Stone at University
of Arizona who's shown this with golfing
tasks where he's had black and
white golfers just putt. Wait,
so this hightest can eat. We're
talking about eating. Well,
think about, think about what it takes
to putt effectively. Are you a golfer?
No. Ryan's not either. So he doesn't
know what he's talking. That's right.
So I'm going to make this
up. You have to constantly,
what we did was we got a miniature golf
situation where each hole changed and
people had to work around
obstacles. This is Jeff Stone.
He runs the social psychology of sports
lab at the University of Arizona.
And here's what he did. He tested his
black and white putters in two scenarios.
Scenario one by using the
word intelligence when we
told them it was a measure
of sports intelligence,
black participants did about four
strokes worse than white participants,
but when he changed it took out the word
intelligence and framed it instead as a
test of your natural athletic
ability there naturally,
the results totally flipped, flipped,
and we had now whites
performance significantly worse
than blacks by about four
strokes. If you look at the recent a
u s open that was played in San Diego,
tiger woods and [inaudible],
a meeting went four days, 18 holes.
They went to an 18 hole
playoff on Monday. Yes,
and still tied. Sudden death. We go on
tiger finally won it on
the first playoff hole.
Tiger Woods. When's the third us
open championship by one stroke.
So when you talk about four
strokes, that's a huge difference.
All right, so here's my question.
Stereotypes are powerful. Okay,
that makes sense now, but in terms
of understanding how this works,
can you make this tactile for me,
like if the stereotype it's having all
these effects is like a thing like a,
like a little Gremlin that bites,
like when in the test taking process
does it actually like do it's damage.
That's going to be way open to debate.
What does seem to be clear from the data
according to Eric Day and Ryan Brown
and Claude Steel,
is that the Gremlin only seems to appear
totally when the test is sufficiently
hard. If the test is easy,
that's important to point out
a these effects don't happen.
It's not that the Gremlin is not
there. Well, he walks in with you,
but he doesn't speak necessarily
until things get challenging.
As soon as the test gets difficult,
that's where the voices kick in,
which means that for most of the tests
everybody's doing about the same.
It's only at problem number 17 the
one about co-signs and factorials and
whatever where things start to go wrong,
and at least that's the
theory at that problem.
The black student starts to stiffen
up a little bit. That's right,
and Claude Steele's measured this.
Their blood pressure's elevated,
their short term memory is impaired.
It's that flicker of frustration through
their body that wakes up the Gremlin
who starts to whisper in their ear,
I don't know if you can do this.
Oh Shit is what they say about us.
True. They don't think you can do it.
All the usual stuff, and even if
the student doesn't believe it,
which is likely so you
don't have to believe it.
That's the kind of insidious thing here.
Just the fact that he has now
this extra bit of mental chatter,
that little guy whispering, well,
it's a distraction and that makes their
performance go down just a little bit.
Hold. This dialogue is keeping from being
a hundred percent focused on the task at
hand, which is solving these problems.
Who the real subtle
power of a stereotype isn't that it
prevents you from doing the thing you want
to do.
It distracts you for just a beat
from doing the thing you want to do.
And that may be all the difference.
Oh, so we're almost done with this
particular podcast, but before we go,
I think we should have the letters
section, which I'll do like this
[inaudible] letters, they get letters.
So we have a this letter Jad Abumrad yes.
A number of people have wondered who
we listened to our diagnosis show.
For those of you who haven't
listened to the diagnosis show,
you'll have to listen to it
to understand this question,
but they're very curious what
happened to patient x who was, um,
had pancreatic cancer in the show. Yeah.
We never quite explained to his
fate what he's, or the outcome.
Yeah. Yeah. That's a, that's actually a
really good question. Um, patient x, uh,
had his entire pancreas removed
and um, many years later,
his is doing fine. He's still alive. Uh,
although the pancreas being a very
important organ, uh, when he was removed,
he became a diabetic. So it's a pretty
radical radical surgery, but it's,
you know, arguably saved his life.
Okay. The next question
[inaudible] this comes from your father
and your mother. Yeah, this is good.
What is wrong with you is
essentially what they're saying.
And I like to join them in that. For
those of you who remember the show, uh,
was a choice when you did this [inaudible]
suddenly in the middle of the show
and for no reason at the
end of a segment, uh,
Jed used a term of opprobrium to IX.
He used the name that is
normally associated with
female dogs and just simply
call the audience [inaudible]
you just called. Okay.
Bitches and then like all hell
broke loose. Yeah. And
I thought at the time,
what it's true you should
eat. It's, it's true.
You should go on record as
being a dissenter from the
beginning. You were like,
why did you, why would you do that?
Okay. So here's the thing. Um, uh,
some people found, many
people found it funny,
many people did not find it
funny. And I sincerely apologize.
The people who didn't you
look, I'm in my thirties. Okay.
I grew up watching MTV, it's
uh, you know, I, you know,
you got with your friends
and you're like, all right,
but she was ready to go
out to dinner a little.
Still actually say that it's
a term of endearment. Oh,
it just popped out during one of
the sessions. Do you remember this?
It was really nice. 1,000 takes
really insulting and stupid,
but no know you didn't find it. This,
this generation card thing on me. So like,
can I get like, I get scared.
Yeah. Right. All right.
So I see that's what all the young
people are doing. You know what I mean?
I got so many people come and say, what's
wrong with him? Why did you do that?
And a lot of them were your age or do
I say it like 19 2021 so I think you're
exactly right. I think it's generational,
but it doesn't even matter at this at,
at honestly. I, I, if I could do
it again, I would take it back.
No offense, no offense meant, I
mean, where it came from, from me.
And I think people who are
my age, they, you know, it,
it wasn't an attempt to be have, it's
just something that happened in the booth.
It was funny. And so we left it in.
We probably shouldn't have come here cause
my parents will not let me forget it.
They're always like, at dinner they're
like, can you pass the salt bitch?
What do you think of the chicken roast?
All right mom. I get it and
get it. There's such good care.
Anyhow, I guess we should
go. Good. All right,
so radio lab is funded in part
by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
the corporation for public broadcasting
and the national science foundation also
by nurse Nestle,
who will try to get back to bed and
totally into sleep as soon as possible.
Right. I'm Jeddah boomers and this
leads, like I said, I don't know why.
I never know what you're going to
say. No, I don't. I really don't.
I'm Jad Abumrad I remember crawling, I
guess catch up with you in two weeks.